yes okay
so the next session for today is titled
actually as uh
genomics in agriculture but
i will actually take the liberty to
change it into omics in agriculture or
into the promise of multiple omics
technology in agriculture that
one can
one will
have or one will get an introduction to
from
from a very short presentation today so
i welcome you all one more time and
before i even began i want to uh
before i even began to introduce the
topics and introduce different aspects
of the topics i want to show you uh the
complexity of
bringing or of considering
plants into or mix studies or the
complexity that the interaction that the
plants
as an organism that it has with these
surroundings brings to the ohmic studies
in order to the familiar omics like
genomics metagenomics transcriptomics
and the proteomics and even metabolomics
there are a couple of omics that we do
not
often hear about so one of them is
one of them is
volatilomics which is
considered as a subset of metabolomics
this characterizes
excuse me this comprehensively
characterizes
profiling of high vapor pressure
compounds that can be released from the
plants so this becomes very important in
the event of stress or improvement of
other
natural situation for which the plants
will have different uh signature of
volatilomics consider compared to the
ordinary volatilomics signature so
similarly spectronomics is a study of
photosynthetic functional traits of the
plants and this is used to better
understand both the natural variability
in vegetation and function and the
variability in the function in response
to environmental stress and change so it
becomes very important because i want to
enlighten you that
before
before our normal methods of
understanding the green fluorescence or
understanding the greenlines or
greenness of the plants
our farmers use this
technique these spectronomics but not
directly but indirectly by
judging how green or judging the
fluorescence of the plants and when to
when to uh
supplement it with necessary pesticide
or when to supplement it with the
necessary uh irrigation pattern and this
this this study or this ohmic will
become extremely important because not
all the plants can be analyzed and not
all of them
can be analyzed in the event of mass
production or in the event of
[Music]
mass
[Music]
optimization so uh a remote sensing
possibility of economics is being
explored uh
and under
um
and the satellite satellite based uh
identification of uh different plants
species based on spectronomics is also
being employed or is also being explored
currently so these are these are all
very rare fields uh which
require extremely high specialization
and and they are being currently
explored in multiple parts of the world
and that's where
plant uh omics is actually moving to
so so to give you some sense of
introduction we all we all know that
agriculture is not
not only a major occupation for few
nations but also is a way of life it's a
way of culture it's a way of custom for
majority of the
countries and majority of the nations
the majority of the continents so
cereals and food products and like rice
wheat barley corn and others have always
been considered important food in human
populations over different continents
and different era so for thousands and
thousands of years
people are using breeding technologies
people are using selective breeding
people are using domestic selection
based on that
based on the different characteristics
and phenotypes of these crops
with and then based on the selective
regulation and selective breeding of
these characteristics
they would
continue to breed to reach or to attain
wanted characteristics that is going to
maximize
the yield or maximize the survival
ability of the plants in the condition
in which they are
grown for so significant progress uh has
been completed in taste nutritional
value and productivity but other uh
i mean progress in other areas like uh
like stress response or like
yeah like response to stress or response
to
salinity or response to
high heat which is very i mean
increase exposure to heat and light and
dust which which becomes extremely
important in the event of climate change
and and
these areas or these progresses in these
areas are being currently explored in uh
in great detail so last 10 years
the last 10 years were considered
to be the new era of bioinformatics and
computational biology in the
life science section on the plant
science uh plant life science section so
involvement of these computer science in
the area of plant biology has changed
the way people usually do research
related to plants in in previous decades
so groundbreaking progress in in
sequencing technology and groundbreaking
path-breaking
analytical technologies
that has evolved in the few last few
years
has made a call made these made this
approach cost effective and nowadays it
is extremely common for any experimental
or agro based experimental lab to use
sequencing based methods to study and to
uh
and to optimize and to develop
characteristics and phenotypes that are
uh extremely important in the um
in the plant production uh field
so
so in in this
in this
continuity a comparative genomics of the
uh models uh comparative genome genomics
of the species uh for um between a model
plant and between non-model plan can be
extremely helpful in discovering
organization of these genes and
comparative comparison between the
organization of the genes with respect
to each other and comparison between
between how the information is
transferred from the model crop systems
usually is
are usually used
much
less or much plant species with a lower
complexity and how the
information and organization of this
complex information is being transformed
transferred from the model systems to
food crop systems like rice or like
maize or like wheat
in the event of water crisis or in the
event of salinity so according to
accordingly the use of multiple omics
and the use of genomics and
bioinformatics and the combination
bioinformatics in combination with
selective breeding would likely to
increase the ability of these
crop species to be used as
biofuel feedstocks and therefore
by employing
these genomics and multiple omics
technologies in combination with
selective breeding will increase the use
of renewable energy in the modern
society and help us thrive
better in for the future challenges that
we have so
one of the useful applications or
successful applications to say
that that has
that that
that is
directly that one can directly evidenced
evidence from the omics of the
application of omics and gene based
editing
in agriculture is the pest control for
crops using specific genes from bacillus
turin gncs so this particular gene can
help help
control number of serious pests that
have been successfully
employed and successfully uh tested in
cotton mason potato so when when these
crops get
these bt or bacillus syringes genes
inserted into their genome so they
develop ability to resist or to deter uh
insect outbreak and and to
and that
and
and also
resist pests that are seed that
seriously uh decrease or that seriously
harm these uh
plants and crops and thereby
increasing and improving the nutritional
quality of these crops such as efforts
has been employed in in
in
in enormous scales in western countries
like us in australia this picture is
actually from from an australian
university which employs or which
publish this particular result
so yeah
so this uh um
so such efforts and such
characterization of
of such possibilities of gene editing is
also
carried out in in multiple labs in india
to name a few napgr and other
labs in india is also exploring the
possibility of identifying and
understanding the genetic variety of
crops that are specific to india and in
comparison to crops that are found
elsewhere and
scientists have actually succeeded in
transferring genes to rice
to enlarge the levels of vitamin a for
example the enlarged levels of
supplements and nutrients that rice can
provide and to enlarge levels of iron
and other micronutrients and this
success does have a deep impact and
in
in reducing incidence of anemia and
reducing incidence of deficiency in
vitamin deficiency and in iron
deficiency and even some in some extreme
cases uh blindness that are caused in
some um yeah in some specific parts of
the world so
so another such example and this this
this comes from an apgr example also is
is in developing cereal varieties that
have greater tolerance to soil
alkalinity and
they are they are also been
constantly
up yeah
explode for their ability to
to deter or to
to grow in in the presence of ion
toxicities in the soil and these
and the variety of different cereals and
chickpea varieties that will be uh that
are free of aluminium that are free of
other toxic
toxicities and
and
and
other
increased
micronutrients products that are being
also
constantly explored that are being also
constantly
checked for
so these varieties and and studies in
this direction actually leads
agriculture
to and leads agriculture to and expands
the expands the reach of agriculture to
poorer soil areas and therefore adding
much more agricultural land to the
global production base which for which
the demand is going to increase in the
coming years
because of twofold so one fold because
of increase in population and the second
fold because of the climate change many
existing
soil areas or existing rich soil areas
are constantly being converted into
wasteland or poor soil areas because of
the
changes in environmental conditions so
researches and efforts in in such
direction is extremely important and are
being
handled with utmost care in multiple
countries to name a few india africa
australia
europe and et cetera et cetera so
to go with the flow another important
application is in the area of meta
genomics in agriculture so this has
shown
extreme
yeah this this is shown to be extremely
appropriate for
for identifying and for representing
complex patterns of interaction that is
occurring among the microorganisms that
populate the soil and also populate the
plant tissues and also populate
different organs of the plants so
moreover metagenomics also showed to be
extremely useful in tracing or in
tracing or in
in
in
converting
converting the composition where one
identifies the composition to be poor or
where one identify the composition to be
a presence
composition to be composed of presence
composition to be uh
a composition that is identified to be
present for virulent
factors and and by transforming uh these
microbial
microbial society within the soil or
within the different organs of these
plants one can actually bring back the
uh
natural uh defense system of the plants
to fight away a specific uh
specific stress condition that the
plants are undergoing this this is this
is also an extremely upcoming
era because this era is already been
underlined as metagenomics or microbial
era where
the application of metagenomics in
various
fields and in way and their impact in
various
research areas are being constantly
explored and are
developed and the
methods and profiling methods and the
analysis methods are being
constantly researched on and developed
further so in in this respect one more
comics that is metabolomics
is a very uh chemistry-based alchemy uh
based uh emerging field in the world of
omics and it is normally used to scan
all the metabolites present in the
sample using sophisticated uh
instruments and
and
this will also this also becomes an
extremely important uh
uh field where as i have already
mentioned the volatilomics is is already
getting gathering lot of
acceleration and
and
gaining lot of popularity in the plant
biotechnology uh area so
to to summarize in a nutshell uh the
goal of plant genomics is basically to
understand the genetic and molecular
basis of all biological process in
plants and this will help us
relate to this into the complex
interaction that the plant species has
with its uh
with this environment and this will help
us understand um
what is essential in allowing
what is essential for the plants
for efficient maintenance of the
biological resources and in and for
developing a new
varieties that will help us
improve the quality and that will help
us reduce the economic burden and that
will help us reduce the environmental
burden that we put on the soil and that
will help us expand the agricultural
reach to other
to other countries where agriculture is
not being the
dominant uh foot yielding
source due to other various reasons
while there have been uh successes in
identifying
critical genes
and in identifying or introducing a new
genes as we had already mentioned before
for agrogenomic improvement the
mechanistic understanding of how
such an effort is functioning is is
still
on how such an effort
or such an such
[Music]
process
actually helps
in developing or in maintaining specific
agricultural phenotypes is is actually
lagging because of the complexity of the
plants plant genome systems and plant
cellular system
presents itself on the complexity that
actually
increases
with the presence of its uh
interaction or complex interaction
with its environment and and non-uniform
noun uniformity of this interaction also
plays a lot of uh
part in in
in
in a in a uh
um in a consensus effort uh like whole
genome project effort uh uh that that is
still lagging for uh plant sciences so
that is in in this context uh instead of
studying
genomics or instead of studying
metagenomics or instead of studying
metabolomics as a as a separate entity
just like how
cancer genomics are cancer multi-omics
is being employed to understand
cancer and to fight away fight off
this deadly disease there is a need to
take the leave from clinical
applications of bioinformatics and
multi-omics integration
in human disease
translation science and there is a need
to take that and there is a need to
integrate information across
different hierarchy and different
biological sales
scales
so as an example uh from left to right
we can have the genomics genome sequence
and we can have the epigenomic marks and
we can have a chromosomal conformation
of this planc plants genome and we can
have transcriptomics data and we can
also we have to and we not we can but we
have to uh consider the plant phenotype
which which is a subject of genetic uh
selection for thousands and thousands
and thousands of years and we also have
to take the environmental and the
ecosystem factors and the challenge in
such a setup is to
is to how
practically and conceptually integrate
all these multiple different
information so that that information
will help us
help us improve the uh
improve the plant uh output or improve
improve the uh quality of the
agricultural products that we are
actually developing so the challenge
is there and hence
because of these challenges there is an
exciting opportunity to do such multiple
levels of data integration um
include
some of the
other omics that i actually missed out
like metabolome and like other
environmental data also to understand
how plants and how the agricultural
product productivity
changes depending upon these different
omics platform so
that is that is it for uh for the
introduction to
a greek agri genomics or that is what it
is called agrigenomics are omics in
multiple
omics in applications to multiple
agricultural
efforts and
to introduce you to such
such a system or to introduce you to
genomics and genomic analysis
in agricultural background the omixlogic
platform has a project that specifically
deals with
gene expression analysis and analysis of
gene expression data in potato to
understand the genes that will
that forms the biomarker that forms the
basis for developing a drought
resistance in specific species of potato
so i encourage and i um
direct you all to go through this very
short lesson and that will really help
you
appreciate and understand the
ugly genomics
effort and agree on the
inference that one can gain from
applying bioinformatics analysis and
applying genomics analysis to
agricultural
system
so i can take some questions here if you
have any
and yeah
please type in